Ankara was ignored and Sarah Champion
was expelled so that's how the left
dealt with the two brave people they've
had you stood forward
um if you're a conservative or if you're
on the right or whatever if you speak up
against this issue it doesn't harm your
life it doesn't ruin your political
career that's how I would describe the
split now I'm enormously grateful to
anyone who is you know politically read
or left-leaning or communitarian or
whatever who speaks up on this issue
especially if they have power because
they are doing something enormously
Brave which is telling the truth because
that's a scandalous thing to do if you
belong to the red team while also caring
about this issue but it's clear I think
that punishment for holding the wrong
opinion on this space has been
predominantly applied to those on the
left because
the kind of the deference towards
diversity the religiously held
conviction that diversity is a good
thing cannot be cut away by its critics
and especially not on something as
damning as this Scandal because this
Scandal kind of like
it destroys that entire world view